FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello.
Can everybody hear me
comfortably on the sides?
Perfect.
DICCON BEWES: Can everyone
hear me?
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's
more important.
[INAUDIBLE].
No one responded to you.
DICCON BEWES: OK.
Ignoring me already.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So thank you
for joining us for Zurich's
first Authors@Google event.
What?
AUDIENCE: I heard there was
something [INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Maybe [INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you for
joining us for my first
Authors@Google event
in Zurich.
Tonight, we welcome Diccon
Bewes, who will be chatting
about his experience of life
in Switzerland as an expat.
Diccon has been living in
Switzerland for eight years
and has written three books in
that time about the culture
that we live in.
He has a history in writing
and books, having been a
travel writer for 10 years in
the UK before his move,
followed by five years
of managing the
English bookshop in Bern.
Tonight, he'll be sharing from
his bestselling book, "Swiss
Watching," which was
a "Financial
Times" Book of the Year.
Please join me in a warm welcome
for Diccon Bewes.
[APPLAUSE]
DICCON BEWES: Thank
you very much.
Thank you for inviting me.
It's great to be here.
My first time at Google,
although, of course, I use
Google an awful lot.
The books wouldn't exist without
it, although I do do
real research, as well, in a
library, not just online.
I am an author and a bookseller,
so I like real
books as well.
Today, I'm going to talk about
what it feels like
for me to live here.
I've been here eight years.
I didn't speak German when
I arrived, and I
knew some Swiss people.
My boyfriend is Swiss.
But I was kind of thrown
in at the deep end.
And I'd like to talk about
what it feels like to be
living in the land of
milk and money.
So that's just a bit about me to
show you there is a reason
why I am here.
And I'd like to start by talking
about this made up
word called "Swissness." It's
a word the Swiss invented to
describe how they feel
about themselves.
It looks like an English word,
and you can kind of guess the
meaning if you're an
English speaker.
But it doesn't really exist.
It's a bit like another
Swissness word, "wellness,"
which isn't the opposite
of illness.
It's actually a nice thing.
It's you go to a spa
for a weekend.
But if you say "wellness" in
England, most people won't
know what you mean.
And wellness in America is
something medical, definitely
not something enjoyable.
So I'd like to take each letter
of Swissness to try and
explain what it means to me.
So the first S is for shells,
which might seem a bit
strange, given that we're
a long way from the sea.
In the book, I call Switzerland
the landlocked
island because it has this
island mentality, being in the
center of Europe, but not
really part of it.
But this is a very special
sort of shell, and
I brought one along.
Now, you all think this is
a coconut, but it's not.
It looks like a coconut,
I know.
And it feels like a coconut.
But it is, in fact,
a Swiss person.
And that doesn't mean that I'm
saying all Swiss people are
small, brown, and hairy--
although some are, I'm sure--
or that you want to throw things
at them all the time.
It means that they have a
very hard outer shell.
So it's quite hard to
get to know a Swiss
person easily or properly.
And it's because the hard outer
shell protects their
private sphere.
So in Switzerland, it's
very normal to
separate public from private.
And when you arrive here, as an
English speaker especially,
the coconut can feel a little
bit cold, a little bit
unfriendly, a little
bit distant.
But what it actually is is
respecting your privacy,
respecting your private sphere,
and taking time to get
to know you, taking time to
let you into their shell.
Now, sometimes it can happen
quite quickly, especially if
you're dealing with a
Swiss person who's
lived abroad, for instance.
But other times, it can happen
very, very slowly, because
once a Swiss person
calls you their
friend, it means something.
A friend here is a friend
for life, not
just a friend on Facebook.
It actually means something.
So they take their time
to call you a friend.
So for example, I go swimming
two, three times a week at an
indoor pool in Bern.
And if you go the same time,
same day, over and over again,
you see the same faces.
And if you're an ignorant
foreigner, you say hello to
these people you don't
know, because you
recognize their faces.
And then about three years
later, they say hello back.
English-speaking societies--
and this isn't my idea.
It's been around for
a long time.
The classifying of societies
as coconuts, or
English-speaking societies
are peaches, typically.
And that's the soft
outer flesh.
It's quite easy to get
toknow someone.
You can be chatting to someone
at a bus stop, and you've
swapped mobile phone
numbers by the end.
The outer flesh--
every stranger is a potential
friend, rather than a
potential enemy, not
to be let in.
But it can feel a
bit superficial.
It can feel like you go straight
through to the flesh,
and you don't really
know anyone.
And it's the hard inner core
which is really the bit that
is protected.
So your very close family.
So it's the reverse
of a coconut.
And the trouble with being a
peach in the land of coconuts
is you can get very bruised
a lot of the time.
And so I get a lot of emails
from expats living here
saying, now I understand why my
neighbors are polite, but
in three years, they've never
invited me around
for a cup of coffee.
It's not that they're
unfriendly.
It's just they're very formal
and a little bit distant.
So it's all about respecting
boundaries.
W is for weather.
British people love to talk
about the weather.
It's our main topic
of conversation.
When all else fails, talk
about the weather.
In Switzerland, it's not such a
great opener with people you
don't know.
In private, the weather
is a topic.
But using the weather to start
a conversation or to get to
know someone is kind of
illogical for Swiss people,
because it's not really
worth talking about.
This is a typical British-Swiss
weather
conversation.
I would come in from outside
and say, oh, it's cold out
there today.
And the Swiss person would
say, well, it's winter.
And that's because for
me, that's the start.
I'd say, I know, but did you
see, it's going to be 19
degrees at the weekend,
or it was even worse
this time last year.
It was minus 30.
And then we would have a
conversation about the
weather, and it lead to other
things, even if I didn't know
that person.
Whereas for the Swiss person,
I've stated the obvious.
It's cold.
So therefore, they state
the obvious.
It's winter.
And that's actually the end
of the conversation.
It's not the start of
the conversation.
So it can feel like getting
through this coconut shell
with small talk is like banging
your head against a
brick wall.
And mainly because small talk
here is about this big.
And it's partly to do with a lot
of small-talk topics are
too invasive of someone's
shell.
So you don't ask someone's
marital status.
You don't ask if they
have children.
You certainly don't talk about
the price of your house, all
of which are perfectly
normal topics of
conversation in Britain.
Partly, here, because almost
everyone rents, but partly
because it's much
too personal.
And to become too personal too
quickly is to invade someone's
private sphere.
So you have to remember, it's
not being unfriendly.
It's just getting to know you
in a Swiss fashion, which
takes a little bit longer.
Baby steps.
The small talk needs
baby steps.
And the most important thing
is remember the humor is a
private thing, generally,
in Switzerland.
It's a bit like sex and money.
It doesn't appear in
public very often.
You can tell jokes with
your friends.
You can tell jokes
with your family.
But in a business environment,
especially with people you
don't know, then it implies that
you're not taking that
meeting seriously.
If you start the meeting with a
joke or a funny story about
something that happened on your
way to the meeting, then
very often, a lot of the Swiss
people will look at you and
thinking, well, are you here
for business or pleasure?
Because you're not respecting
the boundaries.
So be very careful about
using humor.
Of course, if you're a
foreigner, you get away with
an awful lot.
They just think,
oh, foreigner.
And so you can tell jokes, and
people will laugh politely.
But it only goes so far.
And of course, the weather
in Switzerland is
worth talking about.
It has great extremes.
Plus 41 is the highest
temperature.
Minus 41 is the lowest
So it is often worth
talking about.
I is for introductions.
Very important in Switzerland,
because in almost any
situation, social or business
but especially social, you
don't do what I did when I went
to my first dinner party
here in Switzerland.
I didn't really know anyone.
I knew my boyfriend.
I knew the hosts.
There were about 30 people
there already.
So I did what any normal English
person would do in
that situation.
I went and hid in the corner
and waited for the host to
take me around and introduce
me or for someone who I
vaguely recognized
to come over.
What I certainly would never do
is go up to someone with my
hand out and say,
hi, I'm Diccon.
For me, as an English
person, that's very
American, very forward.
Hi, I'm Diccon.
I'm your waiter this evening.
But for Swiss people, who are
actually quite reserved,
sitting in their little coconut
shells, one of the few
times they come out
willingly is when
they arrive at a party.
The first thing you're supposed
to do is go around
and greet everyone who's
already there.
It takes some time.
And literally, the first
thing you do, before
you even have a drink.
So it can be that if there
were more than 30 people
there, half an hour later,
you've just about made it
around the room, and
you're gasping.
And you're just like, please,
someone get me a drink.
But it's very important, because
even if you never
speak to that person the rest of
the evening, you have done
the polite thing and introduced
yourself.
And of course, if you know the
person, then you can spend a
couple minutes chatting.
But you both know that at some
point, you have to move on,
and you will have
to come back.
So it's not impolite to then
say, I'm sorry, off and off
you go doing the round.
The hard thing is leaving,
because when you leave, you're
supposed to go around and
say goodbye and remember
everyone's name.
And for me, that's
very difficult.
Very often, I'm the only
foreigner in the room.
I have a strange name, anyway,
even for English speakers.
So people remember my
name and my face.
And so they come along and say,
well, goodbye, Diccon.
And I'm left, oh, oh,
are you Martin?
Are you Stefan?
Because nearly every Swiss
man is Martin or Stefan.
Oh no, you're over 60.
You must be Hans [INAUDIBLE].
It's really embarrassing when
you have to ask everyone's
name over and over again.
So to get over these two
problems, I have two tips for
you, which work every time.
First--
and this is why all Swiss
people are punctual--
arrive first.
Then you stand there.
You have your drink.
You can chat with whoever
you want.
You don't have to do anything.
Everyone else has to do the
round, and you stand there
relaxed, having fun, enjoying
the evening.
So there's always that scramble
for the door at one
minute past 7:00 when everyone's
been told to arrive
at 7:00, because everyone wants
to be first and not have
to do this round.
Secondly, when you leave, wait
until someone else is leaving.
Then follow a couple
of steps behind.
Listen to them go,
oh, I'm sorry.
I've forgotten your name.
And then you come along and
say, well, goodbye,
[INAUDIBLE].
It was lovely to meet you.
And everyone's amazed that you
have this immense memory
because you've remembered 35
names which you learned in 10
minutes three hours ago.
But in fact, you're cheating.
And of course, no one cheats
in public in Switzerland.
So no one expects it.
It works every time.
S is for a word which doesn't
exist in any of
the four Swiss languages.
Spontaneity.
I lived in London
for a long time.
And in London, if you're in
someone's neighborhood, you do
go and knock on the door and
say, literally, oh, I was in
the neighborhood.
I thought you were in.
Because if they were to see you
walking down the street or
saw your update on Facebook or
whatever, and say, Diccon
didn't come and say hello.
They would be really offended.
In Switzerland, it's exactly
the opposite.
What I learned very quickly is
when I first arrived, I didn't
have a job.
I went to school in the mornings
to learn German from
[INAUDIBLE] onwards.
And in the afternoons, I
explored my new city.
And I did know a couple of
Gregor's friends, and I knew
where they lived.
And I'd be walking past
and think, oh,
so-and-so lives here.
So I'd ring the bell, and there
would be this person
with this look of utter
shock on their face.
Did we have an appointment?
And I thought, well, it's not
the doctor's surgery, but no,
I was just spontaneously
passing by and thought,
maybe you're in.
It would be nice to chat.
And so we'd stand on the
doorstep, making uncomfortable
small talk for 10 minutes or
so, and I would finally
realize that I was never
going to be invited in.
And after this happened two or
three times, I realized that
spontaneous visits are
uncomfortable because the
Swiss person is not prepared.
They haven't cleaned the flat.
They haven't bought
the Rivella.
They haven't made the cookies.
The haven't got everything
perfect.
And a lot of Swiss people
are very house proud.
And because the house is inside
the shell, whereas a
lot of British and American
people use the house as a
social extension, in
Switzerland, the house is part
of inside the shell.
So they're very proud of it and
always keen to show it in
the best possible light.
So if you turn up unannounced,
it may be always perfect,
anyway, but it could not
be quite perfect.
So you have to plan
a little bit.
If I say to my Swiss friends now
I'm used to, well, let's
go to the cinema sometime.
And they'll get out
their handy--
not their mobile phone but their
handy-- and say, well,
how about 17:35 on the
14th of April?
And you go, OK, that's fine,
and get used to making
appointments three
months ahead.
But I have learned that you
can be spontaneous.
You just have to plan
your spontaneity.
It's a very Swiss concept.
So I send a text or put a
message on Facebook or
whatever and say, I'm
off next Friday.
And if the weather's nice,
there's a high chance I'll go
for a walk, and I may wander
through your neighborhood.
And about 11 o'clock, it's
possible I might
ring on your doorbell.
And if you happen to be home,
we could maybe sit down and
have a chat for a few minutes,
if you're free.
If not, no problem.
And of course, they know that I
will turn up, and I turn up
at about two minutes to 11:00,
just to feel a little bit
spontaneous.
And everyone's happy.
I ring on the doorbell
unannounced, roughly, and
they're ready for me.
Everything's tip top, another
phrase that went out of
fashion in England about 1935.
But here, people love
to say tip top.
It feels like I'm talking to my
grandmother all the time.
Swiss francs.
Swiss people love money.
And I'm not saying that
in a mean way.
I'm saying actual, real money,
not pretend money like we have
in America and Britain, plastic
and money that you
never really see.
Real money here.
I worked for five years in a
bookshop, and it was a big
surprise to me, having worked
five years in an English
bookshop 100 years ago, where
most people pay with plastic.
Here, over half of the customers
still pay with cash.
And it's no surprise at
all if you're Swiss.
But if you're British, and it's
your first week at work,
and you're on your own on the
shop floor, and the woman
comes up and puts a book on the
counter, which costs 25
francs or so.
And she gives you a purple
piece of paper.
And you look at it and think,
I've never seen a note with
three zeroes on it.
1,000 francs.
It's like $1,000 just
on the counter.
And so I look at it and look at
here, and she looks at me
and looks at it.
And she's obviously thinking,
why is this stupid man not
just giving me my change,
like in any other shop?
And I'm thinking, well, I didn't
even have 1,000 francs
of change in my till.
But also, shouldn't I hold it
up to the light or call the
police or something?
Because in Britain, our largest
note is a 50-pound
note, which you never see,
really, unless you're a bank
robber or a drug dealer.
But normal people, you tend not
to get them very often.
But here, 1,000-franc
notes are normal.
People think they are normal.
And it's a sure sign that you
are a tourist or a newly
arrived foreigner if when you
go to co-op with a 200-franc
note, you still apologize when
you hand it over, you say, I'm
awfully sorry.
It's all I've got.
Because you're buying a bottle
of Coke for one franc 20, and
the cashier looks at you, well,
why are you apologizing
for giving me money?
It's normal.
My father has been visiting
Switzerland
for eight years now.
And he's still surprised when
the cash machine gives him a
200-franc note, because in
England, you're lucky
if you get a 20.
It's normally 10s and 5s.
And what's interesting here
is the attitude to
money is very different.
It's all about trust, because
Swiss society runs on trust.
Swiss people trust each other to
make the right decision, in
a political sense, because
we have direct democracy.
So it's a system of referenda.
So the people always have a say,
or can always have a say,
either at the beginning of a
process, like with the ban on
new minarets.
It was a referendum which now
has to be turned into law.
Or it's at the end of the
process that they have to
ratify a treaty or say yes to
joining the United Nations,
for instance, which didn't
happen for many, many years.
So the Swiss people are
involved, but they trust each
other to make the
right decision.
And the same with many shops.
I worked in a bookshop
in Bern.
We had tables outside the shop
with books piled up on them,
no member of staff there.
And the shop trusts people to
just pick them up and bring
them inside.
Rather like my local co-up,
brings down the shutters at
night and on a Sunday.
And outside, there's still
compost and plants and
everything.
And they're still there
in the morning.
So it's all about trust.
And the cash society promotes
that trust, because if, like
us, you order a new fridge,
you go to the
shop, you order a fridge.
You give them your
name and address.
A few days later,
they deliver it.
No one's taking a deposit.
No one's taking a credit
card number.
All they've done is deliver a
rather expensive fridge and
say the bill will
be in the post.
And the bill comes in the
post, and you have a
month to pay it.
And it's all very different
from when I worked in a
British bookshop, where if we
took an order over the phone,
it's like ordering on Amazon.
You have to give your credit
card details before you even
send the book out.
So it's very much a
trustful society.
And the cash is part of that,
because a lot of Swiss people,
debt is a four-letter word.
They don't have mortgages.
And a lot of Swiss people do
not have a credit card.
About a third have
a credit card.
About a third don't have
And about a third have a credit
card for going shopping
in America.
And really, it's because they
don't trust credit.
They don't trust internet
shopping in the
same way as we do.
We've got a lot of customers
who would find a book on
Amazon, print it out, and come
and order it in this shop,
which for me was wonderful, as
a bookseller, but completely
strange that they didn't trust
putting their personal details
into a big website like
that or give them
their credit card details.
I pay my mobile phone bill
here by direct debit.
A lot of my Swiss friends
think I'm crazy.
Why on earth do you let a
company have your bank details
and take money each month?
It's because it's convenient.
But it's all about trust.
So it's a very interesting
reversal, or maybe a throwback
to how it used to be.
The other interesting thing
about the Swiss money is the
coins haven't really changed
since about 1870s.
In 1874, Helvetia, stood
up on the coin.
She used to be sitting down.
She stood up.
That was a momentous change.
And in 1978, an extra star was
added around the edge of the
two-franc, one-franc, and
half-franc coins.
Those are 23 stars
for the cantons.
There used to be 22.
And they had to squeeze an extra
one in when Jura became
a separate canton in 1978.
But apart from that, they're
pretty much the
same as they were.
So it's quite usual for
sometimes in my change, I'll
get a coin, which is 1930s,
1940s, and it's still doing
the rounds.
I don't really like
to touch it.
I don't know where it's been.
It's been in many, many
different hands.
But I come from a country where
we change our coins
practically every 10 years.
They get smaller.
They change shape.
They introduce new ones.
And here, it's very stable.
It doesn't really change.
Whereas the notes, there was a
major revolution in the notes
about 10 years ago.
They used to be taller as well
as longer, each note rather
like the British notes.
And then they decided, one,
you couldn't use automatic
machines that easily.
And two, the big notes, like
the 1,000-franc note, were
just too big for people's
wallets.
So they made them all the same
width, but each note 11
millimeters longer than
the one before it.
It's very precise.
And then you get wonderful
things, like each note has a
little symbol for blind people
to know what the note is.
So 10-franc note is a
little dot inside a
circle that is raised.
And this is the kind of thing
you never really notice until
you research a book.
N is for names.
And that's not me.
That is Basel Fasnacht, which
is coming up, one of the
biggest festivals
in Switzerland.
Really worth visiting, but
only if you like lots of
music, lots of confetti,
and lots of people.
If you don't like any of the
above, then don't go.
Just watch it on television.
Names here are also very
important, partly because you
have to introduce yourself all
the time, even on the phone.
If you phone a Swiss person,
particularly in the
German-speaking part, not so
much in the French and
Italian-speaking parts.
But in the German-speaking part,
very often, they'll pick
the phone and just say their
last name, which is very
unfortunate if they have
a funny last name.
I had a customer who
was Herr Wank.
And every time I called him,
he would just go Wank?
I was like, really?
Here?
Now?
And it's too abrupt for me,
whereas in England, it's like,
well, good morning.
This is Diccon speaking.
How can I help you,
if you're working
in a shop, for instance.
But names are very important.
I once had a customer who I
had said, good morning.
Diccon speaking.
Can I help you?
And she said, well, I need to
know your last name before you
can help me.
I said, OK, it's obviously
very important.
The actual name itself
is partly controlled.
It's not very strictly
controlled.
There isn't a list of first
names that you have to give,
have to choose from.
But the first name you give your
baby has to be approved
by the community registrar.
You have to give the baby a
name within three days.
You can't take the baby home
and think, well, she looks
like a Michelle.
We'll call her Michelle
after a week or so.
The name has to be given before
the baby leaves hospital.
And there are certain rules.
So you can't use bad-boy names,
like Judas and Cain.
You can't use family names
as first name,
so no Harrison Ford.
You can't use place names.
No Paris Hilton.
Hurrah.
You can't make up names just
because they sound nice.
Or you can't give a
baby a name which
would open it to ridicule.
So for instance, if your surname
is Head, you can't
call your son Richard
if it were in an
English-speaking country.
You can't call your son Adolf
Hitler like a couple in
America did a few years ago.
So anything that will harm the
child emotionally, physically,
mentally, is not allowed.
And it has to be approved
by the registrar.
It sounds very controlling, but
it's actually for the well
being of the child so that you
don't get children like the
little girl in New Zealand who
was called Talula-Does-The-
Hula-From-Hawaii,
all hyphenated.
That was her given name.
That would never be allowed
here, and probably
rightly so, I think.
Which is why you get a lot of
women called Doris Muller.
E is for Emmentaler, possibly
the most famous Swiss product,
Swiss cheese, as it's generally
called in some parts
of the world.
And the interesting thing about
Emmentaler, it's one of
those Swiss products that
everyone knows is Swiss.
And typically, Swiss
firms, like Swiss
people, are very modest.
They're not wonderful at
shouting to the world, we've
invented this thing.
It's wonderful.
It's great.
This is the best thing
in the world.
They say, oh yeah, by the way,
we've invented something
rather interesting, and
maybe you'd like it.
Or not even that.
They just put it out there and
hope it sells itself somehow.
So there are lots of Swiss
inventions which are famous
but not famous for
being Swiss.
So Velcro, for instance, the
Toilet Duck, electric
toothbrush, LSD, absinthe,
really useful everyday things.
Cellophane, tin foil.
These are all Swiss inventions,
but pretty much,
even Swiss people probably
don't know they're Swiss,
because they've just been
invented, and they think, oh,
that's great.
And out they go.
And so it's very interesting
to see Swiss firms now
changing slowly to deal with
social media, to deal with
different forms of selling,
because it's not really in
their genes to be very forward
and to be very proactive.
So sometimes, it can be hard
for them to enter into the
big, wide world outside
their coconut.
So Switzerland, in a way,
is like a coconut.
The mountains are the shell,
and it's very nice and
comfortable in the
internal market.
But selling to the outside
world can be scary.
And as for the Emmentaler
itself, well, the holes are
officially called eyes.
And they are, officially,
the CO2 released during
fermentation by the bacteria
that are added So in other
words, they're bacteria
farts that are
trapped inside the cheese.
But it has to be said,
Emmentaler, my favorite part
of the cheese is the hole.
I tend to leave the rest.
Penultimate S--
unfortunately, "Swissness"
has lots of Ses.
I had to work really
hard with the Ses.
It's for Sundays.
Sundays were abolished in
America and Britain
about 20 years ago.
Basically, Sunday is
like any other day.
You can go shopping.
You can do pretty much whatever
you want, whereas
here, Sundays are still
something special.
Not necessarily a day of
religion, because although
it's a little bit more religious
here than in other
countries, it's not
that religious.
Some cantons are Catholic.
Some cantons are Protestant.
You only really notice when
the Catholic cantons have
holiday which the Protestant
cantons don't.
And you think, oh, I'll
go to Lucerne today.
And you get there, and
everything's shut because
they're celebrating Mary going
to heaven or Mary having a
little lamb or Mary
doing something.
And the Protestant cantons, of
course, are hardworking.
They have far fewer holidays.
The best place to live,
by the way, is Ticino.
That's 15 public holidays, as
opposed to eight in Bern,
because they celebrate whatever
their saints are doing.
It's an excuse for a day off.
So Sundays is not down
to religion.
It's about having
a day of rest.
That's why the shops aren't
open, except in the stations
or the airport.
That's why you can't
do your recycling.
It may be God's holy day, but
you can't save the planet,
because if you do what I did
and put some bottles in the
bottle bank on a Sunday, you get
told off very quickly for
creating too much noise.
You also very often can't do
things like clean your car,
mow the grass, wash the windows,
do any DIY, because
that's all disturbing someone
else's peace.
And in buildings where you
have communal laundries,
sometimes the laundry room is
actually locked on Sunday.
So you can't even
do your washing.
And it's not about controlling
your life.
It's about making sure
that everyone
has a good life balance.
So what do Swiss people
do on Sunday?
Well, typically, there's
the cinema.
Visit friends, as long as you've
told them in advance
that you're coming.
Go to a museum, because they're
usually shut on
Mondays, because they can't
cope with opening
every day of the week.
That's too much.
Or you go for a walk through a
lovely place like this, the
Eiger Nordwand, north
face of the Eiger.
It's one of my favorite walks.
But a Swiss walk is not
a British walk.
A British walk is a stroll
through a meadow for an hour
or so, finishing at
a pub with a pint.
A Swiss walk is at least five
hours long, has height
differences of 500 meters,
definitely no pub at the end,
and you're a panting wreck
behind all your Swiss friends,
who have marched off with their
sticks and their boots.
I went on one walk.
Never again.
I now meet my friends
at the top.
I take the cable car and
say, well, I'll meet
you there for lunch.
That's fine.
And I bring the picnic.
And they do the exercise.
And I just get up three hours
late, because they all get up
at 6 o'clock in the morning
on a Sunday.
And the train is packed, because
it's a beautiful day.
And it's like rush hour.
And you have to run
to get a seat.
And I say, I'll get up at 9:00
and catch a later train and
meet them at the top.
That's what Sundays
are about here.
And it actually takes a bit of
getting used to, after living
in London where everything
is 24 hours.
At the beginning, I was
thinking, oh my lord, it's 4
o'clock on a Saturday.
Nothing's going to be open until
9 o'clock on Monday.
And you have to rush to the
supermarket, because
otherwise, you're not going
to have anything to eat.
Or you have to face the scrum
that is the Migros in the
station, where very often, it's
one in, one out, because
it's so busy inside.
But you get used to it,
and you actually
appreciate your Sundays.
The difficult thing when you
first arrive is that Sundays
aren't just Sundays.
Holidays are Sundays as well.
So on holidays, everything
is shut.
So logically, the day before a
holiday is a Saturday, even
when it isn't, because a
holiday is a Sunday.
So on the day before Good
Friday, for instance, Maundy
Thursday, everything
shuts at 5 o'clock
because it is a Saturday.
Now, that you can just about get
your head around, because
Good Friday is the same
all the time.
When it gets difficult is the
holidays that move around and
take you by surprise.
So like the 1st of August, and
then suddenly, you have to
remember, oh, it's
the 31st of July.
Not that it's Wednesday, but
it's the 31st of July, so it's
a Saturday.
Or again, going to Lucerne or
another Catholic canton when
they're celebrating something
that Mary did, allegedly, then
you have to remember that the
day before the day that Mary
did something, everyone has to
get ready and rest and close
early to celebrate Mary's
doing things.
So you have to remember that all
these religious holidays,
which in England, we got rid
of and made into very
anonymous spring bank holiday,
here are still called
Ascension Day and Pentecost.
I didn't even know what
happened on Pentecost
until I came here.
And I learned very quickly,
something to do
with the Holy Spirit.
In my children's book, it had
the apostles with little gas
flames above their heads.
That's how I learned
what Pentecost was.
But of course, remember, the
day before Pentecost is
therefore a Saturday.
So you just have to be
a bit more prepared.
The last S is for Swinglish.
And Swinglish is the English
that a lot of
Swiss people speak.
A lot of Swiss people speak
wonderful English.
[GERMAN].
And a lot of Swiss people
speak their version of
wonderful English, which
isn't always the same.
And the problem is, as the
English speaker, you are
expected to understand their
English, because they think
it's English.
So for instance, in this
picture, if you were to park
your car in a space marked
"car," as a friend of mine
did, she did notice it
was a very big space.
So she parked at right angles,
thinking that everyone had to
do the same so that we could fit
lots of cars in the space.
It's logical.
Space marked "car."
I have a car.
I park my car.
Two hours later, I come back to
my parked car in the "car"
space, and I have a ticket,
because, of course, "car"
doesn't mean car.
"Car" means coach or bus,
typically a tour bus.
That's why the space
is so big.
But to English speakers, it's
blindingly obvious that it's a
space for cars.
So you're very surprised
to get a ticket.
Or your handy.
Go back to England and ask
someone for their handy
number, and they will look
at you, what's a
number that's handy?
One of those I wrote on my hand
in a club last night?
I'm not really sure.
Because you forget that some
English words-- because
"handy" is an English word
meaning "convenient." But you
forget that they have different
meanings here.
You get so used to the Swinglish
meaning that you use
it when you go back to England,
and everyone think
you're a little bit strange.
Far more embarrassing is, for
instance, if you're talking
about your hobbies-- you're
making small talk--
and you're an English
speaker--
sorry, if you're a Swiss person
speaking English, as a
friend of mine did.
And she said her hobby was
riding old timers, which, of
course, for her meant she loved
riding around in vintage
cars and vintage car rallies,
because an old timer is a
vintage car.
But the English person she was
speaking to, who was an old
man, thought that she liked
having sex with old men, and
she was being very,
very forward.
But for her, the meaning
was clear.
And for him, the meaning
It was only when I explained
the two different meanings
that they both went very red.
And then you get invited to very
formal functions, dress
code smoking.
And I'm thinking,
I don't smoke.
And I go--
or even if I did smoke, how
can I wear a smoking?
How can I wear a verb?
Sounds like some weird,
fancy dress party.
Come as your favorite
verb participle.
But of course, a smoking is a
dinner jacket or a tuxedo.
So it can be very confusing
when same words
have different meanings.
There are lots of English
words which
have the same meaning--
snap, online, quickie, Google.
But there are lots of words
which have different meanings.
And sometimes, it can be
very embarrassing.
I remember a customer in the
shop came in and spoke in
English, so I presumed we were
speaking English together.
And she said, do you have that
book about a shag in the woods
with Jesus?
I was very professional.
I kept a straight face.
And I thought, well, it's the
wrong bookshop for that.
And then I realized that for a
Swiss German, the "G" at the
end is the same as
a "K" at the end.
So it was the shack,
not the shag.
And of course, there is a very
famous book called "The Shack"
about a man who spends
a weekend in
the woods with Jesus.
I don't know what they
were doing there.
But then to I went and got
the book, "The Shack,"
and gave it to her.
And it's very hard, sometimes,
for the Swiss ear to hear the
difference at the end between
a "guh" and a "kuh," whereas
for an English ear,
it's much clearer.
And then, of course, there are
situations where you end up
looking really, really
stupid--
or I do, anyway--
which is why I think this is one
of many people's favorite
part of the book, because I do
look particularly stupid.
But I'll read it anyway.
Lots of Ses, so I
need some water.
And this, I haven't been
in the bookshop long.
I didn't realize that people
didn't speak my English at
that point.
"Swiss customer--
'I need a book on cheeses.'
'OK, I'll show you what we
have in the cookery section.
I'll get out our three books on
cheese.' Customer shaking
her head, 'Not cheese,
cheeses.'
At this point, I'm wondering,
does cheese have a plural?
Was it like sheep, with none, or
more like fish, plural when
there's more than one type?
Or was this a Swinglish
plural, like
informations and behaviors?
Not wanting to get into a
discussion on that, I try
again, going with her plural
in the hope that it helps.
'So, you're looking for
something on cheeses.' ' Yes,'
the customer says, 'books on
holy cheeses.' 'Oh, you want a
book on Swiss cheeses.'
Customer, looking me as if I'm
simple, 'there is no Swiss
cheeses.' I'm now thinking
about her singular verb
with her plural noun.
'We do have something on Swiss
cheeses.' Customer now very
irritated, 'cheeses
was not Swiss.
Cheeses was the son of God.'
'Oh, you mean Jesus.' 'This is
what I'm saying.
Books on cheeses.'"
And of course, for me,
it was very clear.
And for her, it was
very clear.
And we just weren't talking
about the same thing.
And for all the other customers
and my Swiss
colleagues, who were helpless on
the floor laughing, no one
coming to my aid, it
was also very clear
that I was very stupid.
And Swiss friends of mine who
have heard me tell that story
many, many times now say,
I still can't hear the
difference.
Because, of course, a J for
Swiss German speakers is a
"yuh," and a CH is a "huh." So
they're very distinct, where
to a Swiss ear, a juh and a chuh
sound exactly the same.
So if you happen to be a man
called Jerry from Vancouver,
you have to be very careful
what you say when you
introduce yourself.
"Hi, I'm Cherry from Wankouver"
is what you tend to
get, because Jerry and Cherry
are exactly the same name.
My boyfriend goes chogging.
The first time, he said, I'm
just going chogging with
friends, I thought, should
I be jealous?
What is he doing?
Something in parked cars that is
vaguely illegal, I'm sure.
So that's Swinglish.
It's the last part
of Swissness.
And that's really the funny
side of what it's
like to live here.
Obviously, there's a serious
side-- the political system,
the geography, the history, the
wars, the people, all of
which I go into in the
book in some detail.
So I learned a lot very quickly,
because, of course,
in Britain, we learn nothing
about Switzerland, apart from
banks and "Heidi."
That's about it.
We certainly don't learn about
Swiss history and the original
cantons or about the direct
democracy system, partly
because we don't even understand
our own system, and
partly because we'd probably
be jealous if we actually
thought, wow, they get asked
every three months what they
think, not every four years.
Seems amazing.
And the country actually
functions.
How can a country function if
the people keep having to make
the decisions?
It's just not democracy
at all, really, is it?
So there is a serious
side to living here.
But I focus on some of the
serious parts and some of the
more amusing parts.
The book came out originally
in 2010.
Very happily for me, it became
the bestselling English book
in Switzerland.
And as Dana said,
the "Financial
Times" Book of the Year.
It's also in German.
So my mother-in-law is very
happy, because she speaks two
words of English, "happy
Christmas." She has progressed
to "happy birthday" now.
So she was very happy
to finally
read the book in German.
It has a different title.
I have progressed from
being a watcher to an
understander, [GERMAN].
It also, very interestingly,
has a toilet on the cover.
This is a very famous Swiss
toilet up in the mountains,
one which you have to walk
to get to, obviously.
And I've even had people send
me pictures-- not of them on
the toilet but of the toilet,
sending me GPS coordinates to
show me where it is
in Graubunden.
It is, apparently, a famous
toilet, but it's a toilet
nonetheless.
And then the French edition
comes in June this year,
again, with a different title,
different cover, just to
confuse everyone, especially
the booksellers.
And last year, a little book
of facts came out called
"Swisscellany," or
Swiss-cell-any, if you're American.
And it's one of those books of
facts that you dip in and out
of and think, well, I never
needed to know that, but it's
quite interesting.
So the Swiss people on the
"Titanic" and which ones died,
which ones survived.
Which cantons have
the most cows?
It's Canton Bern, by the way.
All the Emmentaler cheese.
Or all the characters in
"Heidi," or Swiss winners at
the Oscars and the Olympics,
things like that.
Kind of useful, but
not really.
In England, it's the kind of a
book we keep in the smallest
room in the house.
English people are
famous for that.
You have a little bookshelf
in the loo.
We do in our house.
And all my Swiss friends think
it's very strange.
And my Swiss publisher--
this one was published
in Switzerland--
she still says, but there are
more comfortable places in the
house to sit and read.
But that's missing the
point entirely.
So the first two, the English
version and the German
version, are available
as e-books,
"Swisscellany," not yet.
And my new project, which I've
been working on the last two
years, will come
out in October.
Because this year is the 150th
anniversary of Thomas Cook
coming to Switzerland, the
very first guided tour of
Switzerland.
And he brought a very
adventurous group here.
And it was so successful that
he brought more and brought
more and was brought more.
And Swiss tourism exploded,
whereas before, you had to
have lots of time and lots
of money to get here.
It took two weeks to
get here by coach.
And then suddenly, the train
line arrived, and you could
get here in two days.
And coming as a group
made it affordable.
So it was the trains but also
Cook organizing groups that
suddenly started
Swiss tourism.
So Swiss tourism see it
as their birthday.
So they're celebrating 150
years of Swiss tourism.
And what I did is I did the
original tour that Thomas Cook
did 150 years ago.
Very luckily, a woman
wrote a diary.
I didn't put on a big skirt
and say, I'm a lady.
But I did do what they did,
going around the same places,
the same itinerary, the same
overnights, same hotels where
possible, to see how much
a change, see what
had stayed the same.
This is Switzerland.
Quite a lot had stayed
the same.
Change happens very
slowly here.
Change would not be a winning
election theme for anyone in
Switzerland.
But a lot of things had
changed, obviously.
And those changes, a lot of
the time, the British were
involved, because the British
were too lazy to walk up
mountains, so the Swiss built
trains to take them up.
And they wanted bathrooms, so
the Swiss built nice hotels
with bathrooms.
And so a lot of the stuff
we take for granted in
Switzerland, 150 years
ago, didn't exist.
Switzerland was a very
poor country.
There's parts of the diary where
she talks about beggars
and parasites.
And it reads like she's visiting
an Indian slum.
But actually, she's on
the lake at Lucerne.
And it's a very different
picture of Switzerland.
So it was quite interesting
in that respect.
That comes in October
this year.
It's the anniversary.
I have a website, also, where
I write once a week about
Switzerland--
different topics.
So last week, I wrote about
these strange building poles
you get on flat pieces of
land in Switzerland.
The first time you come,
what are they?
They look like anorexic martian
spaceships have landed.
And of course, they're showing
you how big the building will
be that is going to be built,
because they have to by law,
so that people can object
if they want.
And if it's going to be a tall
building, they have these
giant [INAUDIBLE] type things
with guide wires to stop them
falling over.
So just little things I notice
or about Swiss news.
Obviously, Facebook and Twitter,
where I also talk
about different Swiss things.
And you're more than welcome
to have a look at them.
You can contact me through
any of them or even
ask a question now.
And I will have some
books afterwards if
you want to buy one.
For those of who didn't get one,
I'm happy to sell them
and sign them for you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, we want to
open the floor to questions,
if anyone has questions about
his book, about life in
Switzerland, or anything else.
I'll bring the microphone
around.
Oh, [INAUDIBLE] is setting
one up there.
DICCON BEWES: You can ask
anything you want.
I may not answer,
but you can ask.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great, so if
anyone else has a question,
then we'll just line up
at this microphone.
That'll make things
really easy.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
I have observed that the Swiss,
in general, seem to
have very beautifully taken
care of gardens.
But you never seem to actually
see them in them.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Have you noticed that--
DICCON BEWES: It's little
elves at night.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
going on there?
Are they just for show?
If they have these amazing
gardens, why don't they--
DICCON BEWES: Because a lot of
Swiss people don't own their
own property--
it's about half the ownership
rate that it is in Britain,
for instance.
It's about 35% here own
their own property.
Most people rent.
And in the cities,
it's even lower.
In Bern, for instance,
it's 11% owners.
So very often, it belongs to the
building, and there will
be a man responsible for them.
And he will come around during
the day at some point and do
the garden, as well as clean
the staircase and make sure
the laundry room is working and
everything, sort of like a
janitor for each building.
And very often, it's a man who
has retired from his normal
job, and he'll have two or three
buildings to look after.
But for people who do own their
own property and own
their own gardens, I think
it is a labor of love.
And they do do it, like most
things in Switzerland, to
immense detail so that it looks
wonderful all the time.
Of course, a lot of people have
what in England we call
an allotment.
So it's a communal
patch of land
belonging to the community.
And you get a small patch
which you can rent.
And there are rules about what
you can and can't grow and how
much thereof.
And you can only have a certain
size summer house and
things like that.
But for many people, especially
if they live in
bigger blocks or flats,
that's their escape.
And they use that instead.
But no, it is beautifully kept,
most of the country.
I think the biggest problem
here is graffiti.
You see a lot of graffiti,
far more than
I ever say in England.
And maybe that's just one
release for a certain part of
society, because society is
quite controlled and quite
perfect in many ways.
The graffiti is an acceptable
way of rebelling.
Thanks.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just a small remark about
the car thing.
The word "car" from "coach"
actually comes from French,
and it seems to have been
completely independent of the
English word, "car."
DICCON BEWES: Yeah, it is.
But the confusing thing is is
that when you're in the
German-speaking part, you don't
really expect to see it.
I mean, that picture
I took was in Bern.
So even if you speak French, you
might think, oh well, but
I'm in the German-speaking
part now.
But I noticed that a
lot of Swiss German
words are French words.
So that when I arrived
I had schoolboy
French, not very good.
And I didn't have any German.
But I knew what [FRENCH]
and [FRENCH]
meant, because they were French,
even though Swiss
German speakers used them.
In a menu, you only
ever see [FRENCH].
It's only when you go to Germany
you realize, actually,
I don't know the German word
for chicken because I never
had to learn it.
Or I don't actually know what
a bicycle is in German,
because you can get by with
using the French.
So yes, that is true.
A lot of French words do creep
into Swiss German.
AUDIENCE: And Italian.
DICCON BEWES: And Italian.
And of course, you get a lot
of Swiss men who have
perfectly Italian names because
they're second or
third generation, and they speak
no word of Italian and
have never been to
Italy, probably.
But they are Swiss Germans
with Italian names, which
confuses me always when they
pop up on television.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
DICCON BEWES: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Switzerland is
one of the wealthiest
countries in the world.
Could you give top three
reasons for that?
DICCON BEWES: I think the quick
answer is I don't know,
I don't know, and
I don't know.
It is a mystery, and it's one
I'm trying to come to terms
with given that 150 years
ago, it was one
of the poorest countries.
There were pockets of wealth--
Zurich, Bern.
The cities with their
guilds and their
traders were very wealthy.
But the countryside was very
poor and really scraping a
living off of the land
and nothing else.
Which is why tourism was taken
on so quickly, because if
you're earning one franc a day
working in the field, which is
what they were-- and
that was what a
breakfast cost in a hotel.
So the Thomas Cook tourists
would come.
And they'd pay for breakfast
what would take
a whole day's wages.
But if you then can earn 10
francs a week, or 5 francs a
day, or whatever working in the
tourist industry, then of
course, you give up the land
and move to tourism.
It's partly that.
It's partly the banks,
obviously.
The banks have been here
for a long time.
Geneva banks have been around
for hundreds of years.
But banking secrecy, for all
its problems that it's now
giving, did mean that a
lot of money was here.
And the banks were able
to lend it out to help
businesses set up.
It's partly the Swiss
are very careful.
They don't spend beyond their
means, generally.
There's no national debt
here to speak of.
And you get votes
in communities.
Like Lucerne, for instance,
recently had a problem with
their finances.
So they voted to put up the tax
to cover the hole in the
finances, which is kind of not
what most voters in other
countries would do.
But they see it as a
responsibility to look after
their community but also
for long-term planning.
So you have a lot of investment
in the train system
and other things.
So it is partly the Swiss
nature to be very
cautious, to plan.
And if you think, even when they
were farmers, they were
farming in some of
worst country in
Europe in terms of farmland.
And yet, they still made
a living from it.
So I think they're very
resourceful, very innovative,
as I saw with all those
inventions.
You can't invent LSD and
not become rich.
Hurrah, a woman.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
confirming my theory of the
little elves coming out in
the night [INAUDIBLE].
It's totally what
I think happens.
DICCON BEWES: It's about 3:30
AM when they come down our
street, anyway.
AUDIENCE: So the public
transport here and the
facilities always astonish me,
because if you were to
transplant that to where I come
from, it would be a wreck
within a week.
DICCON BEWES: Which is where?
AUDIENCE: Pakistan.
So you give the people the
facilities, they'll use them,
they'll tear the seats apart,
they'll take whatever can be
moved, et cetera.
What is this attitude?
How can you build an attitude
of so much respect for
property that we have here?
You said hundreds of years
ago, they were very poor.
Did they have the same attitude
then as well?
DICCON BEWES: Probably.
I mean, I think it's
two things.
One, it's partly the trust that
I talked about, that they
trust each other to
behave properly.
But it's also the fact that
because the system, from the
very beginning, from 1291, when
Switzerland was founded,
it was three cantons together.
They'd never had a president
who's had any power.
They have a president who
changes every year to shake
hands but doesn't
have any power.
They've never had an emperor.
They've never had a
military governor.
They've never had any form of
central control, really.
Napoleon came.
He tried, he failed, he went.
A bit like the story of
Napoleon, really.
And it was the same
in Switzerland.
He invaded, he conquered.
He set up the Helvetic
Republic.
It lasted five years, because
the Swiss just couldn't deal
with central control.
And because they've always
had a sense of,
we are in this together.
We are a community, whether
we're three cantons or 23
cantons or eight
million people.
And so if you make a mess
of the train, then I
have to pay for it.
And so if there's that sense
of communal responsibility,
which possibly used to be there
in other countries-- my
parents talk about Britain in
the 1950s as if it was some
sort of utopia, which
I'm sure it wasn't.
But there is that feeling that
Switzerland sometimes is the
same as another country was
maybe 30 years ago.
And so there's still that
feeling of community here.
And if you have a problem, or if
someone wrecks the trains,
then it can be decided by the
people what happens in terms
of, does the train company
get more money?
Because at every level--
community, canton,
or country--
the people can decide.
So in Bern, for instance, we
recently voted on should we
extend the tram line
out to the suburbs.
Where else in the world would
you vote on that sort of
minute detail?
Or should we build bus stops
with a roof over them of not?
Or should we extend opening
hours to 8 o'clock
instead of 7 o'clock?
And things like that.
It sounds like very detailed,
boring stuff.
And sometimes, it is.
But if the people are asked all
the time what they think,
and the rules are made by the
people, then I think there is
a bigger sense of communal
responsibility than if they're
told what to do.
It's just a theory.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I'd be curious, since you only
hear an outsider's view of
Switzerland, I'm curious what
Switzerland thinks of all its
outsiders here in the country
and if we're changing the
country or they're changing
us, sort of that whole
[INAUDIBLE].
DICCON BEWES: Oh, how diplomatic
should I be?
I think as in any country,
you will have a divide--
typically a left-right
divide--
on the view.
When I first arrived in 2005,
the first election campaign I
experienced was the one with the
black sheep, the one that
would be classed as racist in
Britain, with three white
sheep kicking a black sheep
off the Swiss flag.
Now, of course, even my not
right-wing Swiss friends say,
well, it's just turn of
phrase, the black
sheep of the family.
But for me, it was overtly
racist and
shouldn't have been allowed.
And I think it fostered a
climate of latent xenophobia,
even if you're white
and Christian,
an acceptable immigrant.
I have still experienced
insults, abuse, because I
speak high German, although my
German isn't so high anymore.
It's a bit polluted.
But in the shop, people would
speak to me in Swiss German,
and I'd reply in high German.
And a couple of people got so
angry we had to call the
police because I was speaking
that Nazi language.
But you get that in any
society, of course.
There's intolerance.
But I think here, it's accepted
by the general
populace in a way that I don't
think is acceptable.
So therefore, what in other
countries would be passed as
extreme becomes mainstream
here.
And I've noticed that over
the last few years.
And of course, it is exacerbated
by the increasing
number of immigrants.
Since Switzerland joined
the [INAUDIBLE]
area and free movements of
people within the EU, despite
not being an EU member, a lot
of Germans, especially, have
moved here.
And in Zurich and Zug, you hear
a lot of German voices.
And to me, that's wonderful,
because I can
understand them perfectly.
But I can understand also why
a lot of Swiss people--
Swiss Germans--
feel insecure about that.
There's this big love-hate
relationship between
Switzerland and Germany.
It's a bit like Canada
and America, only
the other way up.
It's like they're taking
over our culture.
We're different from
them, but we speak
roughly the same language.
Is it a dialect?
Is it a language?
Is it an accent?
And it's all to do with Swiss
national identity.
And then, of course, you just
have the fact that Switzerland
never had an empire.
So whereas Britain has had
centuries of immigration from
different cultures, different
races, different religions, in
Switzerland, it's a
fairly new thing.
Even the immigrants in the '60s
were Catholic and white
because they were Italian or
Portuguese or Spanish.
And then in the '90s came white
Muslims from the former
Yugoslavia.
And so it is a new thing for
Switzerland to have to deal
with multiculturalism.
And that's why you have a lot
of insecurities about
minarets, about wearing the
burka in public, about
swimming lessons for girls.
And it's a very public debate,
which is good.
And it's probably more of a
debate than you would get
about it in Britain, because
things are decided by
referendum.
But that being said, because
it's a public debate, you
sometimes hear and see things
which you think, actually, I
don't want to hear
and see that.
It's an interesting situation.
It's sometimes uncomfortable.
As a foreigner here, I
feel uncomfortable.
And sometimes, I feel
more than welcome.
Learning the language changed
everything, except when I go
to Neuchatel somewhere
and then have to
speak my awful French.
But learning German has
obviously made a difference,
because then people actually
know you are making the effort
to integrate.
Integration is a two-way street,
as far as I see it.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm just curious to know how
much of the things you were
talking about--
like spontaneity and the habits
in parties and things
like that-- apply also to the
French and the Italian
cantons, if at all.
DICCON BEWES: They do
to a certain extent.
I think the interesting thing is
when I go and give talks in
Lugano and Lausanne, which are
not the same place, by the
way, with different names,
as someone once asked me.
Is Lucerne, Lausanne and Lugano,
is that just all the
same place with German, French,
and Italian names?
It's kind of logical.
Genf is Geneva is Ginevra.
They all change.
But I think the interesting
thing is when I go and give
talks in the Swiss [INAUDIBLE]
in Ticino, the Swiss people
there say, oh, and of course,
that's German-speaking
Switzerland.
That's not us.
But the expats living there,
almost all of them say, this
is my life, just in French
instead of German.
And it's partly a perception
thing.
It's partly the Italian
and French--
and we mustn't forget the
14 Romansh speakers in
Graubunden.
They want to be part
of Switzerland.
They don't want to be part of
France or Italy, because they
know they would just be another
ignored province and
totally forgotten about.
Whereas in Switzerland,
they have a role.
They have a voice, which they
wouldn't have if they were in
their respective language
countries.
So they want to be part, but
they still feel like a
minority, because they
are a minority.
65% of the population
is German speaking.
And so they want to feel
like they're different.
And of course, there
are differences.
There are differences
in every country.
If I go to the north of
England, I don't even
understand what they're
saying.
Spend the day in Newcastle,
and I'm lost.
And there are very big
differences in any country.
And here, the differences
appear bigger
because of the language.
And I think, actually, from an
outsider's point of view, the
differences are much smaller.
They're still there.
So for instance, you can quite
easily go out for a business
lunch, as I have done, in the
French-speaking part, and
everyone will drink wine.
Which here, doesn't normally
happen so much, because we all
know we'll fall asleep
during the afternoon.
But you still get the thing
where people in
Geneva contact me--
I've lived here four or five
years, and still, my Swiss
neighbors haven't really
said more than hello.
So it's still breaking through
that clique, breaking through
that coconut.
And so every town can
be different.
And I get emails from people,
why didn't you
talk about my village?
It's so different.
It's like, I'm really
sorry I couldn't
talk about every village.
It's not a guidebook.
And of course, there
are differences.
But I would say as a general
rule, what makes the Swiss
Swiss applies in all areas.
Otherwise, they would feel
French and seem French and not
just speak French.
Oh, dear.
A second question.
I must have said something
wrong.
AUDIENCE: When speaking of
languages, why do you think a
country that has four official
languages works in
Switzerland, whereas, for
example, it doesn't work in,
say, Belgium?
DICCON BEWES: Well firstly, I
should point out that Romansh
is a national language, not
an official language.
It's a typically Swiss
hair-splitting definition.
But it means that it's a
national language, but all
documents and everything
and signs don't
have to be in Romansh.
So if you get official stuff on
the government website, for
instance, it doesn't have
to be in Romansh.
But if they're dealing with a
Romansh speaker, then they
have to do it in Romansh.
It is a national language.
But it's only been a national
language since a referendum
decided that in about 1935.
I think here, it is
interesting as to
how they can coexist.
Partly, they all had to learn
one of the other languages in
school, as well as learning
English as well.
And there's a big debate as to
which should come first.
And partly, it's again that
sense of community.
We all choose to be together
as a country.
So we all have to get along,
even though we speak different
languages, because if we didn't,
we would fall apart,
like Belgium.
But what they do is
make it very easy.
So in Parliament, you can speak
in your own language.
And the presumption is is that
people will understand.
And if they don't, it's their
fault, because they haven't
learned your language.
And so there is that
presumption.
I find the further
you get away--
it's called the Rostigraben, the
divide between the German
and the French bit, because the
Germans speak [INAUDIBLE]
and the French speak as
[INAUDIBLE], basically.
Oversimplification.
But it's called the
Rostigraben.
And the further east you get
from it, the less likely you
are to get by in French.
So in Bern, you can get by in
French and in [INAUDIBLE]
almost not at all, whereas
the same applies.
Gregor, my boyfriend,
speaks no French.
He grew up in Liechtenstein,
so he learned English.
So as soon as we cross the
imaginary border, he can get
by in German in Fribourg,
for instance,
because it's almost bilingual.
But as soon as we get further
into the French-speaking part,
they actually will speak
English with
you rather than German.
And he'll say something in Swiss
German, and they'll say,
oh, I don't speak
that language.
And I say something in
English or my bad
French, and it's fine.
And of course, you can go to
Geneva and speak English
almost everywhere, because a
third of the population is not
even Swiss.
But I think it is-- it's an
interesting conundrum, two
religions as well.
And the last war of religion was
1847 with the Sonderbund
[INAUDIBLE].
How come they can get along
with four languages, two
religions, 13 parties
in Parliament?
And yet, it still functions.
And it's partly to do with
everyone is included all the
time or has the chance
to be included.
Not everyone is included,
because a lot of
people don't bother.
And obviously, none of the
foreigners can be included,
because we don't count
in electoral
terms, political terms.
But everyone has the chance
to have their voice heard.
No one can say, I
wasn't asked.
No one can say, I'm
not important.
What I think isn't important.
And so you always have that
chance to have your voice
heard, which I think is possibly
what makes it work.
In Germany, you say [GERMAN],
which means a nation that is
only held together because
they have the
will to be held together.
It's much easier in German.
They exist because they want
to, not because of
geographical boundaries or
political boundaries or
religious boundaries or
language boundaries.
They exist because
they want to.
This side of the room
is being very quiet.
I'm not leaving until we get one
question from over here.
Well, that worked.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Pascal.
DICCON BEWES: I know.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So much for my nationality.
No, I was actually wondering
if you have noticed any
particularities when the Swiss
is actually outside of the
coconut, when he goes
[INAUDIBLE]?
DICCON BEWES: You mean
outside Switzerland?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, when he
goes abroad, is he--
DICCON BEWES: He
becomes Swiss.
AUDIENCE: He's probably
easy spottable.
DICCON BEWES: Basically,
he becomes Swiss.
There is a famous saying that a
Swiss is only Swiss when he
leaves the country.
And when he's in Switzerland,
he's Bernese or
Ticinese or a Thurgauer.
And so you're only Swiss when
you leave, because when you're
here, your canton is
more important.
Because Switzerland, as an
entity, is only 150 years old,
roughly 1848.
Before then, it really was a
confederation of individual
almost city-states or
country-states.
I call it an island.
It was really more like
an archipelago.
And sometimes, it feels like
26 little countries roughly
going in the same direction,
because each canton has its
own laws and flags and police
and education system and tax.
It's a bit like the states in
America but even more so.
So I think Swiss people
can become more Swiss
when they're abroad.
And they actually talk to other
Swiss people much more
willingly than they do when
they're in Switzerland.
And they become much more house
proud about Switzerland
and become a little bit less
accepting of criticism than
they would from people
who are actually
living here, for instance.
But I think that's the case
for a lot of people
when they go abroad.
They defend their country a lot
more than they would at
home, obviously.
And also, Swiss expats, the
so-called "fifth Switzerland."
You have the four national
languages here, and then the
fifth is all the Swiss
living abroad.
Some of them, I get emails from
them saying either, oh,
it made me so homesick.
That's just what I remember.
And when I visit my family
and everything,
it's just how it is.
And then others say, you're
got it completely wrong,
because they are remembering,
little bit rose colored, what
Switzerland was like
before they left.
And so they feel the urge to
defend it if they feel I'm
being too critical.
But I think that's true of
almost any nationality abroad.
I don't think the Swiss are
actually any different.
When they're outside
the coconut,
they become more peachy.
Still waiting.
A questioner.
See now, we're all going
to watch you walk.
It's here.
It'd better be worth it.
AUDIENCE: The very left edge
of the room, as you wanted.
So first thing, please assure
me if I understood well.
In the beginning, Swiss people
are not asking questions which
might be private, against
me, for example, right?
So not--
DICCON BEWES: Invading
your privacy.
AUDIENCE: Violate my
coconut, right?
So how--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
coconut [INAUDIBLE]
as well, right?
DICCON BEWES: Mental image was
very, very [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
DICCON BEWES: Better than
violating your peach, I think.
AUDIENCE: Whatever you like.
DICCON BEWES: Yes, OK.
Pick a fruit, any fruit.
Not the banana, please.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: OK, and--
DICCON BEWES: And
the question.
AUDIENCE: So the question is,
how they dare to ask private
questions when you want to
rent a flat, they ask
[INAUDIBLE].
Depending on who you meet,
they go in more or less
private stuff, right?
And they are ready to reject
you once you don't want to
share some private
information.
They ask about--
DICCON BEWES: I think that's--
AUDIENCE: In my country, I feel
violated with many of
those questions that I see on
those forms and when I am
asked in my face when
I look for a flat.
And how does it go
[INAUDIBLE]?
DICCON BEWES: I think--
I've been lucky in that I've
never had to look for a flat
here, thank goodness.
It's party a difference
between business--
AUDIENCE: Lucky you.
DICCON BEWES: Yes.
Renting a flat is a business
thing, rather
than a social thing.
So different rules apply.
And it's also they want to
be sure that you are an
upstanding person, because you
are going to be living in
their property.
And so they ask you what they
probably think of as moral
questions, like do you do
drugs, or whatever.
I don't know what
they ask you.
But it's also a question here
of sometimes political
correctness or that
privacy boundaries
don't actually apply.
I have a friend who applied--
she was working in a company
already, and she
applied for a promotion.
She's a 30-year-old
woman, married.
In her interview, they asked
her, so when are you planning
to have children?
Now, in England, that kind of
question would be illegal,
because it's nothing
to do with her
ability to do the job.
But as far as the employer is
concerned, it is, look, are
you a good risk for the next
three years or whatever?
So those kind of what we think
of as very personal
questions--
maybe personal questions about
your lifestyle, for instance--
are actually, in the Swiss
eyes, seen as practical
questions to determine whether
to go ahead or not for a
longer term.
I know it's a very two sides of
one coin, and sometimes it
can feel very invasive.
Like for instance when I applied
for jobs here, first
thing my boyfriend says is,
well, your CV hasn't got a
picture on it, because
pretty much, CVs here
have pictures on them.
And I said, well, what I look
like has nothing to do with my
ability to do the job.
He said, yes, but how will
they know if you fit in?
Well, exactly.
Whether I fit in or not has to
do with whether I'm qualified
or whether I'm experienced
enough to do the job, not
whether I'm male or
black or whatever.
And so there are different
rules.
And I think if you come from a
society which has slightly
different expectations
and rules, it
can seem very intrusive.
But I think it's seen
as practical
here, rather than intrusive.
It doesn't help, I know.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because during
talk, you said that during
business events, you should
apply some of those Swiss
rules, right?
To not bring our humor on
the table, et cetera.
But now, I hear that when
there's a business event, some
rules might be broken.
DICCON BEWES: Well, yeah,
but you're not the one
breaking the rules.
That's the thing.
If you then turn around to your
prospective landlord and
say, well actually, are you
married or do you have a
boyfriend or whatever, he would
probably not take too
kindly to that.
So different rules apply
in terms of status.
AUDIENCE: The nature of
my question was how to
distinguish, right?
We, as foreigners,
how to behave.
That was the meat
of the question.
DICCON BEWES: I think the best
advice, really, is behave the
way the people around
you are behaving.
If your boss and your colleagues
almost never make
jokes in meetings, then the idea
is don't make a joke in
the meeting.
AUDIENCE: And still protect
your fruit.
DICCON BEWES: Well, I've really
developed a thick skin,
become a little bit
more of a coconut.
Turn from a peach
to a coconut.
Become a hairy peach.
It is difficult, and it's one
of the hardest things about
integrating here is keeping
your own sense of self and
your own culture but
also fitting in.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, I think
we have run out of
people to ask questions.
DICCON BEWES: Well,
we can leave.
Now we've had one
from this side.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, good.
We've had both sides of
the room represented.
So it's good.
DICCON BEWES: I obviously didn't
look at them enough
[INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER: So thank
you very much for the
presentation, Diccon.
[INAUDIBLE].
He's staring you down now.
[APPLAUSE]
DICCON BEWES: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We'll be
moving from here to the
Android tent in just
a few minutes.
We have App Row set up there.
There will be books for sale in
case someone wants to buy
one of Diccon's other books.
Or if you didn't get a free copy
of the book today, he's
selling the book we
discussed, also.
DICCON BEWES: Or I can
sign the one you were
given, if you didn't--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, yes.
And he's happy to sign, if you
brought one from home or you
got one today.
Great.
Before you go, we wanted to
present you with a thank-you
present for your time.
[INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
a very googly gift.
It's a "don't panic."
DICCON BEWES: Oh, wow.
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE] for
the hitchhikers on their
adventurous travels.
DICCON BEWES: That's perfect
for-- if you've never been to
Bern, which I suggest you do,
because it's Switzerland's
most beautiful city--
sorry, Zurich.
In the summer, you can go
swimming in the river.
And it's a very fast-flowing
river.
It's like a liquid traveling
[INAUDIBLE].
Basically, you jump in, and you
don't have to do anything.
It carries you around
the whole city.
It's wonderful.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And we have
a nice Swiss theme.
DICCON BEWES: Of course, when
they invented Google+, they
thought Swiss-themed cushions.
Thank you very much.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank
you, again.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: So anyone who
wants to join for App Row can
make their way to the Android
tent, and we'll see you there
in just a few minutes.
Thanks.